[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money the ramsay show is a
different kind of talk radio this is all
about you
it's service
oriented talk radio we're here to serve
you we take care of you we answer your
questions sometimes we bonk you on the
head for your own good because we love
you but uh it's all about you the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five christy's new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance will be out in just a
couple of weeks it is still on pre-sale
which is good news for you folks on
pre-sale you can get about a hundred
dollars worth of extras added in we
bribe you to buy the book early
because it helps us with the best seller
lists and it helps us with the pre-sale
numbers the whole bit so
you jump in and it'll help christy out
you will love this book if you're
interested in the subject of balance
and the illusion of balance and so forth
christie will break all of that down for
you in this wonderful new book so be
sure and check it out let's start off
this hour with rochelle in fayetteville
arkansas hi rochelle welcome to the
ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
i have quit a job after 30 years and i
have a 401k plan in it
and i do not know what to do with that
money i have to take it out and i'm not
in retiring age or anything like that
and i need to know what to do with it
okay good how much you got in there
eighty-five thousand oh this is pretty
important then
yeah okay
okay so there's a a couple of rules that
i want everyone to learn
about investing
number one
you do not put money in things you do
not understand
just because i understand them or
christy understands them that doesn't
make it okay you've got to under
stand it
and um so once you do and it's not that
difficult uh it's not you're not
not like you have to go get a degree in
brain surgery or something okay you'll
be all right but um keep it simple uh
and and so the second rule is is that in
order to understand it the type of
financial person you need in your life
needs to have the heart of a teacher
yeah and one of the things that i think
is important rochelle is as you have
someone walk
through this with you
they will break it down they will have
the heart of a teacher so they'll
explain things step by step you can ask
lots of questions and they'll show you
what to do next i'm not an expert on
investing i have an investment
professional that i sit down with so
when i left my job before i started
working here at ramsey solutions 12
years ago i sat down with an investment
professional to talk about retirement
where it needs to go and that type of
thing and that's what they're there for
and we have endorsed local providers
that help you do that that show you
exactly what to do next yeah our smart
vester pros you just click on smart
vester at ramsey solutions and you'll
find someone in your area with the heart
of a teacher now here's what they're
going to tell you to do and let's walk
through it a little bit okay
number one what i want you to do it's
called an i it's called a rollover
you're going to do a direct transfer
rollover into an ira
there'll be no taxes if you do it the
correct way
okay now the incorrect way would be
tell your hr department to send you the
check
they have to withhold 20
so they're going to keep about 20 000 of
the 85 back for taxes because they think
you're withdrawing it and you're not
withdrawing it
and the government makes them hold 20
back so you're gonna get a check for
like 65 000 but you have to put 85 000
into an ira to avoid taxes and penalties
so now you're up a creek because you're
20 grand short so you do not want them
to cut the check to you does that make
sense
yes okay so the direct transfer rollover
works like this you sit down you contact
one of those smart investor pros you sit
down with them you select the mutual
funds that you want to put the money
into
and we always suggest four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international you'll learn about those
and you'll hear those again when you sit
down with a smartvestor pro they don't
work for us but they do stuff the way we
teach and one of those things they're
gonna do it with a teacher with you at
the heart of a teacher now when you sit
down with them you're gonna pick out say
four mutual funds and you're gonna fill
out the paperwork that says
direct transfer on it and that is
paperwork's to be sent to your hr
department they're going to then send
the money directly into those mutual
funds there is nothing withheld on the
money so the whole 85 000 will go over
there where you tell it to go
and there'll be zero taxes on it now
you've got an investment pro in your
corner to teach you and talk to you and
answer questions at any time you are in
control of the money where it's invested
you can change it later if you want to
everything is
uh
you know ready to go and it's completely
in your control and again it's fairly
simple but you just have to fill out the
right paperwork and you gotta have
somebody help you lay it all out does
that all make sense in general
yes sir it does okay
so where were you working what kind of
job did you have
tyson's okay all right why are you going
after 30 years
yeah it did not work out where i was
transferred to at another plant because
i moved
and it just it just not did not work out
in that plant for me
all right
wow
that's a long time to be one with one
company and now what are you to do now
i don't know what i'm looking for
i'm not sure
okay
how old are you
58. okay great well you got lots of time
to start fresh
we call these uh encore careers you ever
go to a um
a music show and
uh when they finish they leave but then
they come back out take a bow and go
again
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
come back out take a bow and go again
okay
yeah so if you want some information on
career and that kind of thing check out
our website ken
coleman dot com it's all free
and ken is our resident expert on
well they've taken the bow going again
that's right trying to find something
new getting clear on what this next
stage and season is for you dave i have
a question even as you're talking about
this rollover when someone is leaving an
old job or has left an old job
how urgent from a timeline perspective
is it that they rolled this over because
i know people that just leave some of
these retirement accounts with that old
job and we've even had calls here on the
show they're like i had this job you
know 20 years ago i don't even know
where it is and i can't find it how
urgent is it that someone do that well
there's no regulation preventing you
from doing it any time but from your
advice so i would just go ahead and you
know it's part of the transition that
you go through i mean you're filling out
all kinds of paperwork when you leave a
job right you know and just make that be
you got to go get your new insurance you
got to go figure out what you're doing
next you got all this and so i would
just go ahead and make it part of that
and because you might forget about it
right or not be able to find it after a
while like we've had those calls for
yeah we've people forget what was going
on i don't even remember how much was in
there i just left and right 20 years
later i'm trying to figure it out now
see that's another reason you take it
with you right you've got more options
in the open market to pick from
you've got more control and you've got
someone that's got your back an
investment pro in your corner when you
do a direct transfer rollover
so we always tell you always take it
from your old job not to your new job
but to an individual rollover every time
you leave
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the year
2021
is the year of christy wright books
every time i look up there's another
thing that we have coming out christy
wright so we had a devotional a little
bit earlier that became a number one
bestseller we've got a book coming out
in just a couple of weeks in september
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to
life balance a major book project and
then uh every year for the last uh six
or seven years i guess we have done a
goal planner and the 2022
christy wright gold planner goes on sale
today yes and this is this is important
for people to know because and i'm sure
you remember this last year dave you got
calls about it like i did but we sold
out early it always does and so if you
want your copy get it now even though
2022 is a little bit away go ahead and
get your copy and then you'll have it
before we sell out and uh and one of the
things you have talked about this is
dave but um about this with the planner
but it's not just a calendar it has
content tools templates that are going
to help you stick with your goals and i
think that makes it more valuable full
life
it's a beast it's a big old thing i mean
it's it's there's a lot i mean just the
shipping cost those things
it's a it's a chunky
monkey man there's a lot but i mean yeah
you've got scripture in here you've got
stuff to do every day things i'm doing
this week it is so well laid out so well
done
and our sales double almost every year
yeah um because the people everybody
buys it they bought it last year plus
all the new people and so the it is a uh
it's a very successful product yeah but
uh just you know
here's the thing okay we don't run out
of books
when we print books we're not going to
run out of books okay we're always going
to have a book available for you
calendars however
have a shelf life yeah
uh in other words this is not going to
be much good by this time next year and
the likelihood of us being able to sell
it this time next year is about zero and
so from a business perspective our goal
is to have exactly the number that you
people want and we won't have to throw
any in the dumpster
and everybody gets one now you know what
the likelihood of all that working out
zero okay so
in lieu of that i'm not throwing them in
the dumpster that means i'm not over
ordering and i own this freaking place
so if you want one they always run out
we plan for them to run out we planned
for the planner
to run out so just to let you guys in on
inside baseball here this is how it
works all right our goal is to run out
at the right time yeah we don't want to
go too soon but just soon enough that
some of you that put it off you get
punished a little bit
last year last year though i do think we
set a record in terms of we sold out
earlier than we ever had we sold out we
actually snuck a speed reorder we did
and still sold out of that even early
people were i mean people would message
me even in march can i get a planner
like no no it's smart oh it's gone
but now's your now's your time we're
telling you early get your copy while
we've got them and uh it's a great tool
now you kept with the same theme with
the painting yeah it's really pretty but
it's also it's amazing how we talk about
this dave but personal development
you're looking at all the different
spokes in the wheel of life you're
looking at all the different aspects of
your life so every month we're focusing
on a different aspect of your life to
help you grow in that area so it's it's
goals it's personal development it's
it's managing your calendar it's all
those things so if you want to make 2022
different by focusing on things that
matter most to you uh the new 2022 gold
planner on sale right now you need to
hurry get your copy they sell it every
year we talked about that at length uh
so prepare go to
ramseysolutions.com they're not up on
amazon yet we'll get them up there in a
couple days but just order it from
ramseysolutions.com from the web from
our store and we'll get them out to you
and they're in stock right oh yeah okay
so we'll go ahead and get it course
doesn't do you don't need it right you
don't have to have it for 2022. it
doesn't have december in it does it no
like 21. no okay so done it's no good
till january 1. that's right but uh but
get it early because it'll be gone yeah
that way you don't have to think about
it again you know to kick yourself later
for forgetting to order it so
ramsay solutions.com get them while the
gettin's good
uh yet another christy wright product
out this year
um i've been busy dave well we can't you
know
if you're awake you're writing so that's
a fact that's just the way it works we
know about you you're going to be
writing i'm going to be talking and
you're going to be writing this is the
way it works open phones here at triple
eight eight two five
two
karen is in tampa florida hi karen how
are you
hi gabe thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um
so dave um
i am a recent widow
um
i have two
uh adulting
college-aged children one who is 21 the
other one is
23
recently graduated and is starting the
process to be financially independent um
yes um so in the process of
gathering everything together after my
husband's
death
one of the things i did was i did start
to um
consolidate all our 401ks and
investments
um i
froze all of his credit and credit card
accounts
um
and i followed one of your videos um
that said don't do much the very first
two months um so i'm
kind of at that point where i need to
start taking some action so it's been
two months and the first
um not quite not quite it's been about
about six to seven weeks now i'm so
sorry what happened
i thank you um
well he is he was a stage four colon
cancer patient he um
unfortunately uh was diagnosed um very
very late
and uh fought a good fight um
but unfortunately lost yeah so y'all
were married what 25 years
um no um that was very sweet of you
we had a 23 year old i was guessing you
know
yeah yeah um we actually were married
a little over 32 years okay
so
um yeah yeah so how are you doing a new
um
hanging in there
some days work has been hot uh work yeah
some days about others um work has been
great um couldn't have done it without
my work family and my church family
um
but my my my question is um we are
um
one of our goals that my husband i spoke
about was helping our kids um into those
adulting behaviors
um and as i started to look at
everything um i'm
very very well set off in our retirement
funding um
and
um i am going to pay off um our mortgage
um
my husband was um very
very good at life insurance so i do have
um
some funds available to me and the first
thing i want to do in the spirit of dave
ramsey
is to pay off my mortgage um which was
also his intent as well so i'm very
committed to that okay um but i have
noticed um that i have with my children
being the age that they're in
um
we did not do a very good job with
thinking about
titling of cars and insurance and
now that i have this sum of money
i really want to protect it
it's something that my husband did and i
know that he would want it to be
something that not only
serves me but also serves my family and
my faith so
so i'm calling
to get an idea of how do i do that do i
title the cards in my kid's name the
kids cars should be in their name and
they should pay their own insurance or
you give them the money to pay the
insurance
okay that was that wasn't my question
yeah and cause if he wrecks and it's in
your name they might come after you
gotcha simple as simple as that and so
it might cost a little bit more on
insurance for it to be in their name but
when mine turned 18 i moved them into
their name immediately
as a as a risk management thing had
nothing to do with i don't like a kid
it did cost me a little bit more in in
insurance
so yes we did do that and then and then
just again with the investments with the
large sums
just take your time
take your time if it takes you a year to
wade into those investments
um
and get everything set up that's fine
you're a very task-oriented person um
one of the ways you feel better is if
you get stuff done i can hear it the way
she's talking right
yep exactly and that that's not a bad
thing um but uh
you know be very careful go very gentle
and slow give yourself room
give yourself room and you're gonna be
fine and you call us anytime we can help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five one
thing we are sure
about personal finance is that it is
eighty percent behavior
it's only twenty percent
head knowledge
so anything in your life that affects
your behavior positively or negatively
is actually more important
than the technical
financial
teaching
the technical finance understanding the
details of an investment important
controlling the person in your mirror
absolutely vital and so when you have
things happen to you
um
you need to give yourself a little bit
of a
somehow we feel like we have to be like
financial superman financial superwoman
even when
we're really going through a hard time
yeah like our last caller who just lost
her husband yeah you know you don't have
to be superwoman well i think it's that
i think also sometimes like you said it
might even be um it can be a coping
strategy where we're like i just want to
do stuff i want to control what i can
control but to your point
there's not a
timeline you have to do all this on and
so one of the most powerful things you
can do and this is with money decisions
but any decision
is just consider the season that you're
in and i don't think we do that enough
dave whether it's with your your health
your family your work your business even
your money when you consider the season
that you're in then you can set goals
and make plans that are
a reflection of what's going on in that
season so the season of mourning after
losing your husband might not be the
time to knock at all your all your
checklists on your uh you know going
through all the paperwork stuff it might
be something you do more gradually over
six to nine months than in those first
um few months and so i think there's
just there's something really powerful
of stopping checking in with yourself
considering the season that you're in
before you put all the pressure on
yourself because sometimes we put
pressure on ourselves and it's not the
right time the right season for that
pressure of that goal well and i think
the reason we do is we we've lost this
we've got this disconnect
as if finance sits over here in its own
little column
of our life this one little silo of our
life and everything else is over on the
other side
and it's like but and so no matter
what's going over in our the big swath
of our life somehow we're supposed to be
okay with the money part yeah or we're
supposed to uh you know uh not do uh you
know not be susceptible to stress
spending or or grief spending or not be
of course you are right and people do
some of the dumbest things when their
personal life is messed up yeah with
money yeah or when their personal life
is going like really really good yeah
and they feel invincible like i got the
midas touch everything i touch turns to
gold and no you don't yeah yeah no you
don't i mean you know you get you get
this high because everything seems to be
working and then you go do something
that's super high risky yeah but in your
mind
because everything's been going good
it's nice it doesn't feel super high
risky yeah so of course it's super high
risky well and i think the the bottom
line too is in any of these extremes
whether you're an extreme of of grief or
healing or even just you know you've got
a lot going on you're busy maybe you're
just super tired
it's hard to think clearly in those
times it's hard to think clearly when
you're mourning it's hard to think
clearly when you're exhausted and just
trying to keep your head above water and
so i think that when you can get into a
space where you can think clearly then
you're going to make better decisions
but if you're just reacting you're just
flying by the seat of your pants or
trying to just
control things to control them you're
not necessarily going to make the best
decisions you need to think clearly and
get out of that in order to make better
decisions
so
deloney talked about this and john dr
john delaney when we were going through
kobe this time last year and people were
in freak out mode that when you're when
your brain is in freakout mode whether
it's anger fear
pain grief
whatever you're just overwhelmed with
emotion
it shuts down your critical thinking
skills yeah because you go into fight or
flight yes
and uh he talked about that and and you
know we kind of all know that from a
common sense but hearing it from a phd
yes made it sound smarter but um
i'm not sure he is but anyway he sure
has a lot of sure has a lot of letters
after his name but um it makes sense
though but yeah so
hint
all of us
have periods of time in our life short
and long
that there is extreme emotion
do not make big financial decisions
during a moment of extreme emotion yeah
the logic part of your brain is
literally not working a hundred percent
of your decisions suck
during that time because you are not i
mean you know i'll give you an example
when people get scared they get super
scared they get desperate
right after you get desperate is when
you fall for get rich quick
and you get conned
because you're like i'm 58 i just woke
up and realized i've got no money
i gotta retire
and they also they go into orbit right
yeah and what they do they go some of
the dumb but get rich quick investing
stuff and they get ripped off
and so they destroy what little
opportunity they had
to actually catch up yeah which you can
do at 58 you're not gonna die you're
gonna make it
a little baby
but you know that when you when i get
desperate
right after i get desperate i get really
stupid well yes desperate decisions are
always bad ones we talk about this even
through entre leadership with hiring
when you're desperate you're going to
make a bad hire because you're just
desperate you're not thinking clearly
it's it's true with anything though we
ken coleman and i have talked about this
when we've hosted the show on fridays
together we have people calling in and
they took a job that was the wrong job
because they were desperate and i was
like man that was a bad decision what do
you do then so desperate that's that's
such a good point desperate decisions
are are always bad decisions i had a
friend that married a woman that he
shouldn't america because he was
desperate that's that's that's next
level that's next level
that costs you a lot of money though i'm
just saying
and headaches and stress and
it goes bad and the same thing could be
true some lady that hired or married a
bad dude i mean she goes both ways
it's expensive mistake yeah serious so
all kidding aside
with all the stuff happening with covid
with
grief
around any kind of a situation
you get fired
well what happens you go through the
stages of grief yeah you get mad you're
in denial
you blame other people it's probably
your fault but you don't come to that
immediately
might not be your fault i don't know i
got fired one time and the guy
i never knew why i got you still don't
know why no and he died so i'll never
find out and he cussed me out when he
fired me so i really i mean you know i
should be nice about it but he's dead
and so but yeah so i one of the things
i've vowed around here over all these
years is if we're gonna let someone
leave they're gonna at least know why
and they're gonna if if at all possible
had a lot of warnings yes yeah a lot of
heads up about it but if you get fired
you get caught off guard
that lady in our earlier segment been
with tyson 30 years yeah didn't work out
yeah oh you heard oh yeah you can hear
the pain yes there's a story there at
the new plant there's a story there yeah
and if all that stuff is in your stomach
and coming up into the back of your
throat
not a good time to buy a house yeah yeah
yeah not a good time to you know
suddenly say i'm going to open a
business and go 400 000 in debt yeah to
medicate the fact that i'm really
hurting pissed off and wondering about
my own
worth in the world yeah personal finance
so the more stable
steady
consistent predictable the person yeah
the higher probability they build wealth
you know i'm curious your thoughts on
this when you said that you made this
reference to starting a business uh king
coleman and i when we were hosting the
show a couple weeks ago we got the
blinds.com question it was this woman
who had had a salon for 22 years
closed it due to kovid and then was not
sure what to do now and in her you know
when they submit these questions we
don't can ask follow-up but open
reopening slum wasn't an option and it
led me to wonder i wonder how many
businesses
closed in covid because of you know
whatever the expenses and all that
but then didn't reopen not because the
business wasn't viable again but because
they were so hurt they're broken they
felt so
like they failed like they were because
i'm
investments
and i had this cool sign and i had to
take it off the wall
it did something it was
it was not just closing a business i
turned the key that's right in that door
the last time and walked away from that
building
it was like the death of a dream
and uh it was a very real thing did i
need to be making major life decisions
of any kind money included during that
time no right
so you know you just gotta at any point
of high emotion positive or negative
take a chill pill
wait a beat
or three before you make major financial
decisions this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five john is with us in tampa
florida hey john how are you
i'm doing well dave thanks for taking my
call sure what's up so through a few
live events um
i was able to pay my house off
sooner than what i expected which left
me with a
i guess a surplus in my emergency fund
with that being said
should i adjust my emergency fund and
invest
oh would i say adjust it should i adjust
it down because now obviously i don't
need as much because i don't have any
bills everything's paid for
and invest the remainder of that
well yeah you're it should be three to
six months of expenses and what you're
saying is you're with a house paid off
you got hardly any expenses right
i have i literally have zero expenses no
i mean you have food and lights and
water and insurance and
electrical and all that
yeah yeah just the basics um
and then on the flip side i also i drive
a 20 year old car and so i've also
considered maybe purchasing a new car
one day obviously not in this market but
in the near future yeah get you get you
a better car which also by the way will
lower your need for an emergency fund
yes because the transmission going out
in that hooptie is more likely than in a
decent car right
correct yes
john have you run the numbers yet of
what um you know your old emergency fund
was based on what the new one is based
on with these new you know lower
expenses so you know about what the
surplus is
um
just no haven't sat down in random
numbers but i figured currently i have
about 55 000 an emergency fund my wife
and i do 130.
so we were figuring probably 25 000
would be
yeah substantial okay yeah it'd be fine
and then you outta your mark some of the
rest of that for the car
and then invest the rest of it or maybe
have a have some fun with the rest of it
whatever you've done great you're baby
step seven man you're rocking it yeah
are you a baby step millionaire yet
uh yes i am way to go way to go that's
all congratulations well done how old
are you
i am 51 my wife my wife is 52 i'm 51.
good for you congratulations that's
amazing yeah thank you so here's the
thing
the
uh
as we have built wealth sharon and i
have noticed we have less emergencies
because we own nicer things
you know it's like the cars i used to
drive were an emergency looking for a
freaking place to happen okay you they
were an emergency they were and i was
driving my emergency you know
and then once you get decent vehicles
and you've got a little margin
you literally have fewer emergencies and
so i don't even
i mean the the chances of us actually
not cash flowing
90 something percent of our emergencies
just out of checking is pretty low
uh these days and so uh you know it
because again
it when you're broke every your life
looks like a country song everything is
an emergency you know
and so it does change over time and the
it's kind of
like oxymoronic you know they always say
well you know the banker will loan you
money only when you don't need it you
know and it's like well you have only
you you know by the time you don't need
an emergency fund right you know yeah
it's like it does it seems like that you
should not need the emergency fund in
the early days it'd be helpful right you
know but no you got to have it when
you're starting baby steps one through
but when you're at seven and you're
hitting millionaire status you're making
130. yeah yeah 25 is going to be plenty
because you got other money and john get
that car i hear your voice you're a
saver i love that about you that's
what's gotten you to this point enjoy
some of that money it is sitting there
and your car's old yeah he doesn't want
to buy it because they're crazy right
now it's all i know but i know but that
emergency that's waiting to happen it's
going to come out of that or it's going
to come out of your emergency fund
whichever way you want to look at it
make sure you get it for christmas
anyway by the way by the time
i like that go ahead and start planning
your christmas gift google
amber's in minneapolis hey amber what's
up
hi dave hi christy hope your day is
going well sure now can we help
i am currently on baby step number two
and at the beginning of the year i
started a youtube channel which has now
opened an opportunity to make some
additional income to go towards my baby
steps
my question is on my youtube channel i
try on and review clothing which
requires me to purchase quite a few
pieces from each brand i generally
return most of the samples like once i'm
done filming um but i'm currently
funding this on a credit card that i
only used for that and i only pay the
minimum balance like the minimum due
each month until i get the refund
at any given time there could be up to 4
000 on this card in rotation
is this an okay way to fund this and
like chalk it up as a business expense
or should i be approaching it in a
different way
um
yes
yes you should be approaching in a
different way having a credit card for
business or personal is a bad plan
because of the risk involved because
it's a bad plan to cash flow your
business but
credit card aside for a second i'll let
dave explain that even more but you
should not be paying for these clothes
these ideally these brands
should be giving you free clothes to
review
for the exposure that you keep for the
exposure you should not be paying to
give them business this doesn't make
sense so your whole business model needs
to be fixed from the inside out aside
from how you're you're funding any
expenses that you have which should not
be on a credit card but i want you to go
to these brands and get them to give you
free clothes giving them exposure how
much are you making on youtube
so the actual youtube portion of it like
i just hit the monetization and it's
like very small 18
yeah like after a month of doing videos
this other platform reached out to me
and they pay me thirty dollars for each
30 second to two minute clip that talks
about each project what's your
viewership
my viewership i am just over a thousand
so still pretty new but i've made in
like the past
oh six or seven months with this other
platform i've made over twelve thousand
dollars
okay
so the risk that you're taking from a
business perspective screwing around
with four thousand dollars
in order to make eighteen dollars or
thirty dollars or up to twelve thousand
over many many months
uh is inordinate
uh i'm not sure you got enough eyeballs
yet on the thing to get them to give you
the free clothes the way christie's
trying to talk about but basically what
you're doing is you're putting yourself
in a position of being an influencer
and uh the way influencers get paid is
they monetize the eyeballs
they come to watch them do whatever it
is they do
and so um
that's what you know and obviously
youtube will pay you and other platforms
will pay you as well
if you can get the eyeballs but a
thousand is not not a bunch you're
getting there though that's i'm glad
you're working this uh so uh what's your
household income overall
so my normal nine to five i make about
86 000. okay
i i want you to set aside two grand
for this business maybe even out of the
business income or three grand
and just prime the pump one time by that
i mean open a separate checking account
that is just for this clothing exchange
process
because if you get stuck if one of these
companies let's say you bought a
thousand bucks from somebody and they
just said oh we're not taking that back
you wore it
um
and so your little return refund program
doesn't work anymore you now ate that
and guess what if it's on your credit
card you now have credit card debt
and so this is the risk that happens
because there's one thing we're sure of
in business
there's three things we're sure of in
business
um
it's going to cost twice as much as you
think it's going to it's going to take
twice as long as you think it's going to
and you're not the exception those are
the three rules of business
and it happens to me around here all the
time i have some great idea i think this
is going to work and we put it out there
and
six years later into the gold planner
christy's goal planner which we launched
today
is a mega successful product the first
year
i'm sure it's a great idea you know
well a lot of dadgum work for not much
money you know and so now it has turned
out to be a thing but it took twice as
long
as we thought and we're not the
exception especially initially and uh no
matter how enthused or enthusiastic or
um
angry i am or christy is it doesn't
matter you know we still got to she's
still got some things have to cook up
they're like good gumbo yeah you know
and so you you and in the meantime
you're carrying credit card debt
and i'm not going to ever advise that
you called the dave i mean you called
the ramsey show you called dave ramsey
christie wright asked about a credit
card you knew you you knew that wasn't
gonna work
i mean that was that that is predictable
we're consistent
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice christy wright ramsey personality
is my co-host today number one
best-selling author and host of business
boutique a huge conference that we have
coming up here in the fall october 14th
through the 16th as a matter of fact dr
john deloney jasmine starr nona jones uh
bianca oltof monique shohan ah maneet's
coming
a celebrity on the uh chef on the food
channel food network and uh also a local
uh entrepreneur owns a bunch of
restaurants in our area and just
world-class lady overall that's cool
yeah and that's a big addition and uh
i'll be there speaking and it's going to
be all about business boutique all about
uh equipping women to make money doing
what they love and this conference has
sold out every single year it is october
the 14th through the 16th there are some
tickets available for here in nashville
and nashville is a great place to visit
it is it's a great uh it's a great city
to to make a road trip out of it if
you've got some friends you all have
side businesses or small businesses
you're working on gather some friends or
even connect online on the business
boutique facebook group and sync up and
share hotels and all that good stuff and
uh it's a jam-packed three days but it's
also one of those that you come home so
fired up and so filled up and you know
exactly what to do you don't have to
feel stuck you know what steps to take
to grow your business where to get it to
where you want to be yeah from where you
are that's where you need to be that's
right and that could be from the dream
stage or all the way from you've got a
pretty sophisticated operation and
you're just wanting to put some more
tools in your belt and so um typically
it's two thousand to three thousand
ladies in this audience yep and um
uh it is um again we've just found that
our hometown of nashville is very
popular
very popular visit uh place to come and
hang out and uh but of course
you know you need to book time around
this to do all that because you're gonna
be in here busy yeah we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna be you know you're
gonna go up to a water fountain to get a
drink we're gonna turn off
it's been cool too dave because i've
noticed even recently in conversations
as we've been talking about business
boutique uh this event every year we
started in 2015
every year this is the catalyst for so
many women that changes the trajectory
of their business truly i was just
talking to someone the other day that
has a
massive worldwide business okay in 20
countries
they're absolutely rocking it
multi-million dollar business
started 2016 business boutique wow and
you hear these stories and you go oh my
gosh that's the moment in time where
something changed and they went home and
did what they needed to do and this
becomes the catalyst so it's a great
opportunity for people to get not only
the information and steps which we give
you but get fired up to believe in
yourself and go home and do it yeah once
you've been stretched you never return
to the same shape yeah and this is a
brain stretching conference your brain
will never return to the same shape yeah
so business boutique uh christy me dr
john dolony
host of other characters that are
absolutely incredible communicators
business teachers will be with you and
october 14 through the 16th you get your
tickets before they're gone again this
thing is a sellout every year you text
boutique to 33 789 check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
but text boutique to 33789
the business boutique conference coming
up this fall caleb is with us caleb is
in los angeles hi caleb welcome to the
ramsay shop
hey christy and dave how you all doing
great great what's going on
well um uh my question is about where i
should put my cash now so i've heard
about your plan for years and i finally
just did it my wife and three kids we
moved into
my parents barn on some acreage so we
could finally you know pay off the debt
um we did we were in a loft you know
every dime that came in went to the debt
just gazelle intense and then we had the
whole ladder you know with the marker
and then you mark it off painted off and
the very next morning we found out we
were pregnant with twins
congratulations
oh i'm so glad you're ready
it's
no for real though like you're right i
mean if i wouldn't have done
that plan you know the stress of student
loans
you know i went to film school
you know it's gone now so here's here's
my issue um i own my own business um i'm
in film production
uh so you know irregular income
do you i know the next baby step is pile
you know three to six months living
expenses etc but i have heard other
people in the film industry call you
before and i remember you said something
something about you know get a much
bigger buffer what what do you suggest
for me right now my twins are due
end of november and we already have
three kids under five so i'm looking for
some advice well while you are you're in
baby step three anyway which 100 of your
spare dollars are going to build your
emergency fund
right uh and so you know three to six
months of expenses now you can go and
build up you know six months of expenses
and you can just keep building it past
that until the twins come if you want
and then you'll just have some extra
money beyond that
aside from the twins aside from the
small kids just the irregular volatile
income with a small business um or in an
industry like the film industry where
it's um
feast and famine i mean you're either
making bucks or you got nothing
and so
that we were in the real estate business
when we came up with this idea because
we had the same thing we could have no
money one month and 20 000 bucks the
next month and so
um right
and so what we did uh it's a dumb name
but i couldn't think of anything else
you think of a mountain
and a valley
and the mountain is that big month that
wonderful month the valley is that
horrible month the value of death right
where you have no money and so we called
it a hill and valley account
so if we were in a valley month we
didn't have to hit the emergency fund we
had a separate savings account to fill
in for a horrible month of income in a
volatile income situation and because
that's not an emergency that's actually
a predictable event
right yeah and do you have a percentage
dave that you recommend for that no i
think what you look at is the volatility
and the volatility creates two things
one is actual arithmetic and it also
creates all this emotion yeah you don't
use the emotion to set the amount
because when you dig down into it
usually
you know you you feel like you have a
ten thousand dollar problem and you
might have a two thousand dollar problem
yeah
and you go look like my worst month
here's my worst possible month
and here's what we need to exist well
you gotta cover the difference right for
two months right and you know it might
be a thousand bucks off you know yeah it
might be two thousand dollars in your
hill and valley account i wish i had a
sophisticated i'm horrible naming stuff
but that's all we called it because
that's the only thing we could think to
call it because we wanted to separate it
from the emergency fund because the
emergency fund is for unexpected events
this is expected
we know this is going to come and so i
think you build up your emergency fund
first and then you build your little
hill and valley account just going
forward regardless of twins and babies
do you have a question about that dave
um for businesses that are super
seasonal like that do you recommend they
have a business version of the hill and
valley or would you just use their
retained earnings for retained earnings
should you do that that's the purpose of
retained earnings it's just to cover
some seasonality and you can adjust your
retained earnings based on you know your
seasonality like
for years around here i we our summers
were slow
because live events are slow
publishing's down in the summer
radio listenership is down in the summer
typically and so our summer's slowed
down now we've got a whole bunch of
other product lines now that don't slow
down so we don't notice it as much but
we used to put some money aside to get
ready for summer yeah you know financial
peace university sales were down and you
know july is way different than all
october right you know that kind of
thing
so we just had to kind of get ready for
that
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today she and i will be doing an
event thursday september the 16th the
take back your time event
uh appropriately named with the launch
of the book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance which
comes out the week before
and uh it's on pre-sale right now and if
you want to attend this
live stream for take back your time all
about balance all about getting control
of your life passes start at only 20
with your event pass you get over sixty
dollars in free
bonus gifts including a copy of take
back your time you can join us in
nashville for the event and a special
book signing with christy or via the
live stream either one just got to tell
us in advance which one you're doing
because we will sell out here in
nashville of course
you can feel balanced even in your busy
life and we want to teach you how the
take back your time live event and live
stream thursday september the 16th text
time to 33
789 time to three three
seven
eight nine so when someone finishes
watching that what is it you want them
to feel
relieved
activated and relieved but here's the
thing we feel so much pressure and guilt
around our time that's why i love the
tagline of the book the guilt-free guide
to life balance this is not a
productivity book it's not an event to
show you how to do more faster multitask
squeeze more in be more efficient i want
you to feel free
to do what's right for you right now i
want you to feel free to spend your one
life on what matters to you we're going
to show you how to do that in very
tactical practical ways by the way
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time it's a great american company use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
today's question comes from diane in
ohio i'm 61 and my husband is 58 we are
doing well financially and have no debt
i'm currently a health coach for a
health management company i'm tired of
playing the corporate game and tired of
being micromanaged i would really like
to have my own practice coaching clients
on healthy lifestyles teaching cooking
classes and controlling my own schedule
i have no idea how to do this without
leaving my current job and making no
money at all for a while what would my
first steps be to start my own coaching
business
well i'm going to start with the
assumption that there's not a
conflict of interest non-compete that
type of thing because she wants to do
what she's currently doing for this
company there's a little bit of of gray
area there
to me in terms of what she's able to do
but i would say for diane uh i want you
to do this the same way i would teach
anyone to start a new thing that if you
have a full-time thing but you want to
start something on the side you start it
on the side and you start by putting it
putting uh the information out there
maybe it's a facebook post you email
family and friends hey i'm going to
start doing this you think about your
pricing do a little research a little
digging of what would your packages look
like what would your services include
how are you going to structure uh your
services and your pricing and so on and
and you start to baby step into it and
the reason we want to do that
is because as you take those first baby
steps
you're going to learn about what
questions you need to ask what answers
and policies and
procedures you need to come up with
you're going to learn what your customs
so
so
[Applause]
new deal fleshed out yeah get some proof
text we call it actually functioning in
the marketplace and then you'll have a
lot more confidence
about your move and you don't have
enough so many false starts that you
give up yeah because you don't have to
give up yeah and so uh the good news is
you'll develop a tolerance for the old
place uh once you once you have a plan
to leave yes that's a good point it'll
increase your frustration with the old
place because you're going yeah just a
matter of time i'm out of here so i can
put up with you right now yeah
brian is with us brian is in panama city
hey brian how are you
i'm doing good thank you guys so much
for taking my call sure what's up
um okay so i was i recently um got
married this past march congratulations
and thank you
and um we were together
we we've been together for the past
three years developing you know just
[Applause]
portal to hell
you want to talk about disgruntled just
get dave talking about technology
talking about how much money i spend on
technology and then i can't even talk on
the phone yeah so um yeah that just get
me started but yeah so that's just life
and um
so
anyway the i think it's good to go back
to um our our lady we were talking about
diane blind
yeah the um
it's always if there's any way you can
when you're starting something
start it on the side and we always the
analogy i've always used the metaphor
i've always used is to
bring the boat as close to the dock as
you can before as you step into it that
way you can step into it not leap
towards it right and hope you make it
when people always ask the question that
way they say how do i make the leap full
time i i work with women every day
building side businesses and that's the
way they ask this question how do i make
the leap to full time and and dave you
and i say this all the time we don't
want you to make leaps we want you to
take steps when you do that you will not
fall as far it will not hurt as much we
want steps not leaps
so word is it brian's on the phone again
hey brian what's up are you there
hey okay so you got married in march and
what's going on
okay so um
my okay so my wife uh her parents
they're they're they're very
very nice people
they've done a lot
for her growing up um they're they're
financially
well-off
and
you know since we became married i feel
like it's our responsibility to um
you know kind of take
uh
i guess a handle on some of the things
like her retirement um health insurance
life insurance those kinds of things
yeah um
yeah right so her dad still has all that
in his possession
yeah her dad still has it in her his
possession and they're kind of every
time we discuss like finances and money
and things like that they get all weird
and
yeah well let me get weird for you okay
your your wife needs to tell her dad
to put the stuff into her name
now
how old are y'all brian right i i agree
i'm you don't you can't say it
okay
all right so that's where yeah i guess
where i'm coming in here um because you
know i i would want to
approach anything whether you know i
want it to be my place and i think when
it has to do with my wife you know we we
um since we've been come married we uh
combined our life got on the same page
where we just became debt free
yeah but it's not your daddy it's her
daddy and it's not your policies it's
her policies right now it's her
retirement yeah and she needs to move it
needs to be moved into her name
now and she needs to call her dad and go
dad
i understand a few months after march
but now it's august so i'm going to come
over to the house and you're going to
sign all the crap
into my name now
and you can be a little nicer than that
but that's the message
these nice people they definitely will
have a lot of money and meanwhile
are control freaks dude and so you know
your wife is nice
it's called leaving and cleaving but you
can't do it they're not gonna listen to
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality my
co-host today the 2022 gold planner on
sale this week at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
very very popular gold planning life
planning
item by christy this is the sixth or
seventh year we've done these things and
they always sell out
and uh so be sure and check out online
at
ramseysolutions.com christy i'm gonna
play papa day for a minute i want to go
back to our last caller okay got a
commercial bearing down on us yep
all right i'm 61 i have three grown
married children all have kids
not 61 yet i'll be 61 in a couple weeks
but close enough
um
when your children get married
you
do not have the moral
ethical
right
to hold on to
their stuff
period
when they reach adulthood
you do not have the moral ethical right
to hold on to their stuff
and so example in our house would be
uh
denise comes home from college
and she sets up her own household within
three months
moves into an apartment with some
roommates
eventually starts dating a guy gets
married um
but when they're engaged
uh i look down and realize there's a
file here with mutual funds with her
name on it
there's the health insurance is still
running through us which is stupid this
is like a grown woman right
and she needs to pay her own light bill
she needs to check the date on her milk
carton
by herself
uh and her mama don't need to do it yeah
and her dad doesn't need to hold her
hand because he looks at her husband as
a little boy yeah
sorry folk
you don't have that option
and when you do
continue your helicopter parenting
into their twenties
you damage the relationship with them
potentially for the rest of your lives
and you stunt their emotional growth
because they're still freaking little
baby children
because you didn't give them any
grown-up stuff to do yeah god that
pisses me off
set them free
the bible says to leave and cleave
so you leave your mama
and take your stuff with you
you know what i heard in that call too
though i wish so bad she had called
because i heard in his voice he didn't
want to talk to him he wasn't supposed
to anyway but even if he was he was he
was bowed up he was ready to talk to him
yeah but it was like this nervousness
like you could hear so like well i don't
know he started out with they were nice
people and i started laughing because i
knew he was lying we both well we both
did because we're like but we're waiting
for the bus where's the butt because
he's a great canceler in a sentence
everything that comes before the word
but means that those people are butts
so then but i wish we could have talked
to her because i got the sense that she
was not the type that wanted to talk to
them
she's been used to daddy taking care of
her no and here's the thing so then
speak up girl speak to that person speak
to the the timid the child the adult
child that's scared to talk to their
parents give them some
some help here is your job as a 20 what
was she saying he was 24 so yeah i think
so yeah she's 23 25 probably give or
take i mean be a grown-up come on
put your big girl pants on
and uh because the sooner you do that
the the
the most one of the most rich
times of our lives in our personal
family is the current time where i have
adult to adult relationships with my
children including my sons-in-law my
daughter-in-law
and
i thoroughly enjoy them as adults but i
that means that i have to
i you know
rachel and i have uh i don't cross
boundaries with her just like i don't
with you and you're you know you're
we're not ken right we've been friends a
long time we've been on our team a long
time we've got a good relationship but i
i there's things i can't tell you to do
it's not my right and vice versa by the
way you know and so you know and the
same thing's true with rachel true uh
and so you know i i wouldn't we could
talk about stuff we can argue about
things we can discuss politics we can
talk about life or religion or doctrine
or whatever else but that's just on a
friend of friend level so to speak yeah
and it's the most rich time it's some of
our ramsay dinners because we're all
loud and gregarious and fun people are
hilarious now but it's like a group it's
like a friend group having dinner right
not you know dad is holding court and
you're all are going to now listen to me
right they quit doing that a while back
i'll just tell you what do you think
what do you think is going on in the dad
in that scenario that wants to hold on
to it does he still see him as a kid
he likes the power control i'm talking
because
because he's he's he's being a twerp
he's trying to hold on to the past and
you know you walked her down the aisle
you placed her hand in his hand dude you
just gave her away that's what they call
that all right what if she's not married
well she's 25 though well the same thing
except there's not a hand there's
nothing right leaving in cleveland
clarified yeah marital relationship but
they're still adults and so what you're
doing is you're tr you're treating your
25 year old like she's 13 and guess what
she's gonna function like she's 13 and
then the rest of us in society have to
put up with this entitled little twit
don't you think yeah you have people
that are uh
five years younger than you that you run
into that are not functioning
at that age yeah emotionally well and
it's a very it's an unhealthy dynamic on
both sides because you have the uh let's
use the daughter in the scenario it
could be a son either way but the adult
child that will not stand up to mom or
dad or speak up to mom or dad or say i'm
a grown-up these are my xyz funds
policies whatever and then you have the
dad or the mom whoever that is
dominant controlling they like having
the power they like being the big you
know big deal in the family and so they
it's it becomes this dynamic that's
unhealthy and on both sides they both
have a responsibility in it is what i'm
saying it is emotionally hard
admittedly
to when your kids reach the point that
you're no longer allowed to tell them
what to do yeah
i used to could just tell you to do
stuff and you freaking had to do it you
know and now i can't do that now i have
to convince you or persuade you like i
would one of my buddies
i've got to talk you into this is good
for you here's why i think this and
depending on how strong i feel about it
you know but i may not even bring it up
at all but this is just reasonable
relationship boundaries and and so
but but it some parents can they have a
real problem
with this boundary of uh
and saying out loud okay this is like a
grown butt human here i can no longer
tell them what to do yeah or i shouldn't
be
telling them what to do
it shouldn't be effective someone should
stop you from doing it whether it's the
person you're doing it to your yourself
your pastor ought to look at you and go
hello you know something somebody had to
give you a little wake-up call you know
ring the bell for you and go
uh you have now moved into a new phase
you no longer can boss them around
and uh because the interfering
mother-in-law when the kid's 32 and she
still rolls her eyes with the way the
chicken pot pies made oh my god
that's a classic stereotype yeah
and it's like you don't get to roll your
eyes anymore yeah
you like have to be polite and stuff
right you know oh my god you wouldn't do
that at your friend's house right or if
you would you wouldn't have any friends
yeah and yet you still think you can get
away with it with those that you love
the most and the closest to you yeah and
so and it does go into the financial
because the more when you don't put the
weight of the decision-making on the
grown child they do not develop the
strength to make the decisions
you have to let them feel the weight of
that rent on their back and i imagine
the weight of the grocery shopping and
you go oh my god look what bread just
did yeah i imagine it has an effect on
the marriage too for those that are
married then it's it's it's stripping
them of some of the dignity of figuring
it out as a couple of communicating as a
couple because mom and dad are still
controlling everything still having a
say still carrying the weight it's like
no like like as a as
you have a fight you run to your mom
yeah
oh my god yeah yeah
i told rachel denise in particular said
when you have a fight and if you want to
call over here and talk to us about it
you better bring them
because otherwise i'm gonna point you
right back at him and go hey i already
told him you're now his problem
you did say that i did exactly say that
you know i said that too
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
tyler is in colorado springs hi tyler
welcome to the ramsay show hey how's it
going today dave better than i deserve
what's up
uh i'm kind of in a funny transitional
state in my life i'm getting ready to
transition out of the military and i'm
looking at living options once i get out
i'm gonna go to college on the gi bill
and
i've been really struggling with whether
or not i should rent or try to buy a
home but in doing some research
it doesn't seem like there's any way
that i can get pre-approved for a home
loan
and i understand that you hate va loans
can you can you clarify as to kind of
why
you you hate va loans so much and also
what your best advice is to me hate
might be a strong term but um
but number one the va loans are more
expensive with fees
and interest rate than any of the big
three fha va or conventional
number two
va loans the reason most people
gravitate towards a va loan is you can
get a as you know you can get a house
with nothing down
yeah and that's that which means you're
too dead broke to buy a house
okay when you buy a house with no money
a house is not a blessing
okay
and so because here because you know the
air conditioner is going to go out next
week
okay so i want you to have a house i
just don't want to have you so that
that's the reason i don't i don't it
causes people to buy a home
and when they're in a position of
weakness rather than strength so what i
would tell you to do is uh rent the
least expensive thing that you can and
let's work on your career and work on
your goals and build up some money
okay so then in that case that leaves me
with one of two options i can either
live with my parents for 350 a month
which
yes that's awesome but how long have you
been in the military
i've been in the military for nearly
five years when i get out and that one
down home that'd be really painful
yeah and and my parents i love them to
death great people but
it's it's it's difficult to live with
them and so my next option would be
um
would be renting a
apartment for about 850 bucks a month
yeah i try to get you a roommate
situation where you can get that cut
down but you don't need to be back at
home
it's just okay it's emotionally going to
be
destructive for everyone involved
okay
and with that though i guess i have some
extra money in the bank that i could use
to float myself on the months that i
don't get paid by the va for the months
that i don't go to school or summer
break or whatever
um
but can you not work
i can work
it's going to be very part time i do
plan on getting a part-time job i
actually have a job lined up already
as soon as i get out so what are you
going to study and how long is it going
to take you
i'm going for a construction management
degree
and it's going to take me four years
i'll get my bachelor's and i should
graduate
by like 2026 somewhere in there all
right
well i graduated in four years with a
business degree
from the university of tennessee and i
worked 40 to 60 hours a week every week
okay
so very very part time is not necessary
you don't have to work that much because
you're not starving to death you've got
the stipend and everything but you also
have to sit on your butt
and all that extra money can go towards
saving up for when you want to buy a
house when you're ready to dollar so the
more you work the more money you have
the quicker you get to that goal
and and if i were you i would take it a
step further and i would get a job in
construction anything you can do around
where you want to be meeting those
people that are doing what you want to
do what you're in school for that's just
going to fast track your whole plan yeah
get it get get your foot in the door and
start learning some hands-on while
you're learning in the classroom and
that's going to be you're going to come
out you know with three
major advantages towards your success
your military career your hands on the
job
training and your academic background
you put those three things together man
you got some really good taste in soup
there i i think you got a bright future
when you do all that and the
construction guys will appreciate you
actually knowing what the flip's going
on from something other than a textbook
all right cheyenne is with us in bowling
green hi cheyenne how are you
i'm doing great how are you better than
i deserve what's up
uh yes um just wanted to say i love you
both and
um me and my husband have actually been
with the ramsey plus since october of
2020 well my husband has currently been
working at his shop for six years he
currently works for a penny factory here
in town
and they are part of the union and his
union
contract will be up may of 2022
now we have about 71 out well we had 71
000 in debt and we currently have about
27 000 left and we have about eight
months from now
he could potentially go on a strike if
the contract does not what you said
uh yeah
oh oh okay i thought it was is it is it
is cheyenne don't you let them make you
confused about your months okay
no you're right okay okay you got eight
months all right so you could be
debt-free and still have a pile of money
by then
i i well that's what i was asking um i
was a little nervous because my
husband's slow season is actually coming
up this fall typically every single year
he's been working there the slow season
starts in september
and
in between september and potentially
february it's very slow and the amount
of hours and the amount of money that
we're used to him getting most of the
year is possibly going to dwindle down
and i'm a little bit scared to either go
ahead and pay off the rest of the debts
that we have or
just pile up cash for a potential strike
because i don't think that he would
possibly get paid for the union strike
it used to be about two hundred dollars
a week that he would just pay what's
your current household income
um eighty thousand
okay yeah you can be debt-free and have
the money by the time you need to
you only have twice you only have 27 000
left
yes yeah and current currently
slow season means these hours go down to
how many
um instead of him getting um about 70
hours a week it'll probably bump down to
40 50 hours a week maybe
wow so he works 70 hours a week a lot of
the year
yes and uh most of that is volunteer um
they've had a lot of people quit uh you
obviously know what the pandemic a lot
of people don't want to keep their jobs
that is definitely his case
when the whole pandemic started they
were actually the busiest they've ever
been in their entire life and so
a lot of people have been quitting
lately and so that is keeping his
overtime available that's cool
so they've been slowly hiring people and
i'm just nervous because i'm i'm the
person in the family how many times has
his union gone on strike since he worked
there
um since he worked there it has not gone
on strike which is how long
uh he's been working there for six years
and the last time the longest they went
i think was a month or a month and a
half
yeah you're worrying about something you
don't need to worry about
okay
okay you have a month and a half you
have a month and a half problem and
you're to be debt-free you're nervous
about what-ifs and we don't plan based
on what-if scenarios cheyenne you've got
a plan to get debt-free you're going to
get debt free you're going to have some
cash if this even happens which it
likely will not yeah i want you to pile
up a big old pile of cash and be
debt-free and then you will actually be
the most ready for a strike you've ever
been since he's worked there
and still probably and you're going to
do all of that by may but um the
likelihood of them going on strikes
probably pretty low
um
they're just rattling their sabers
and
you know carrying on because to posture
for the negotiations and so forth
because what's happening is most factory
situations are behind
and the last thing they want to do is
get further behind uh supply chain has
been so screwed up by covid and the
whole you know production
means of production manufacturing
everything's been so screwed up the last
thing that unless the union is being
completely outlandish
the employer is going to sign up
so they're not they're in a position of
weakness it's a bad year for their
contract to come up for that employer um
because they need to produce produce so
i just i i think you're gonna be okay
and i don't think you need to uh worry
quite at the level you're worrying being
intentional and thoughtful about it yes
i would do that and i think it's wise to
you know look at the tea leaves see
what's coming but i think you're
overstating it yeah yeah
you're going to pile up that cash shine
and that's going to give you a peace of
mind that you don't have right now when
you have that you can see that you'll
you'll even know even more that you're
going to be okay
christy wright good show thanks for
having me it's fun ramsay personality my
co-host today james childs is our
producer laura johnson filling in for
kelly daniel who we can't seem to get to
work these days
she's going to kill you for that one
[Music]
she's on strike
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage is a big
indicator you might be a baby steps
millionaire this is an everyday baby
steps millionaire theme hour we're
talking to real millionaires this hour
only if you have a million dollar net
worth or greater i want to talk to you i
want to learn how you did that did you
win the lottery did you inherit the
money um or did you work save and invest
and live on less than you make how did
you do it because other people want to
do what you did if they can
do what you have done
a lot of the reason people don't
strive to be financially successful is
they believe
that the system is rigged against them
and if you believe that it's rigged
against you then you never work towards
winning
if you thought the game was rigged why
would you play the game
i you know i don't want to get you don't
get in a card game where you know the
outcome is already there because there's
a shark at the table right
you don't want to do that and that
that's logical
but what's not logical is the that
you've believed lies from people who
have political agendas
and or are just living in a victim
mentality state
and don't believe
that they can win and our goal around
here is to give you hope and people that
steal your hope or ideas that steal your
hope falsely
um
then you know i it's my job our job at
ramsay to go to battle with those things
and so when people say here's here's
what people say
stupid butt stuff
absolutely false
statistically proven to be false
almost all of america's millionaires
inherited their wealth
absolutely a lie
we did the largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america airtight
research technique
no question i defy you to find anything
we did that was statistically incorrect
or against basic research doctrine
there's processes you use to do airtight
stuff so you don't fall into your own
self and and prove what you think is
going to prove so here's what we found
we did we studied 10 167 millionaires
in-depth surveys with them everything we
could learn about them so that we could
show you
whether you can do this or not
79
of them inherited zero
that's eight out of ten
another five percent inherited money but
it was less than a hundred thousand
dollars mathematically impossible for
them to become millionaires because they
inherited money i got five thousand
dollars when my granny died from the
sale of her farm that did not make me
wealthy
okay
so another five percent so that puts us
at 84 percent another 5
inherited substantial money from a
family member
after
they were already millionaires
so they already got a million five net
worth granny dies leaves them 250 000
but they did not become
millionaires
because of inherited money
period
and so this great socialistic lie
by the entitled socialist community
is is it's it's stealing people's hope
so we started doing this show why ever
so often we do a millionaire theme hour
we're going to take calls from those of
you that are millionaires oh by the way
that was another five percent so five
and five and 79 is 89. nine out of ten
millionaires in america today
did not become millionaires because of
inherited money
so the great question is
what did they do
that's what we want to answer this hour
and then you can decide if you can do
that too
my contention is you can do it and i can
show you how
so an everyday baby steps millionaire
theme hour
regular people just like you just like
me becoming millionaires we want to talk
to them if you have a net worth of a
million dollars or greater you call me i
want to hear how you did it tim is our
first one he's in des moines iowa tim
what is your net worth
uh net worth is about 2.4 million
excellent
give me a little breakdown on that
between what types of and where is that
money located and what categories
oh let's see real estate um cash and
small mutual funds and real estate real
estate is how much
uh we're pushing 1.6 okay a lot of real
estate good okay how much in mutual
funds
um i'd say about um
most of the rest of that there's a
little bit of cash in there too
okay so that so like is that retirement
accounts then
yes so about 800k in retirement accounts
yes gotcha okay how old are you uh we're
43. how much of this did you inherit
uh well i like to consider the fact that
we
invested it from the bst program it's a
i call it the sweat and tears program
so none
uh what was your best year working
lifetime income household income in your
worst your
lifetime
uh i'd say best year was 2
40. um worst year was 16 000. okay what
do you do for a living
i'm a
building consultant uh insurance
consultant claims consultant okay what's
your degree in
i do not have a degree no no don't have
a four-year degree okay what was your
gpa in high school
uh high school
uh enough to get a diploma okay
you graduated like i did thank you lordy
yes exactly
all right so uh you're a real estate guy
how much of this wealth do you feel like
you have uh because you borrowed money
to become wealthy
um i'd say zero
okay so how did you do the real estate
if you weren't borrowing money to do it
uh because we cash flowed um and we just
flipped houses
we took your profits and rolled them
back in
yes sir and so the you never really had
a whole bunch of mortgage debt you
didn't do like the uh uh nothing down
real estate club no no no absolutely not
just trying to make sure people here
what really is going on
and so you're 43 years old what's your
advice to the 23 year old version of you
that's out there listening can he still
do it and what should he do
um yeah he can do it he should have done
it
20 years ago
because it is possible we we became debt
free 2018 we did the debt free scream
there at the show with the family
it doesn't matter how many kids you have
we have 11 kids wow and
yeah
and tears pregnant with the 12th are
expecting
in december
um and
if
you
want to accomplish it you can
and if you hear all of the different
advices out there financial advice out
there there's a lot of different advice
there's a lot of different good advice
out there but
once you actually
follow
the baby steps
and you actually apply it and you get
your brain straight around get your head
wrapped around what this actually means
and what you can accomplish then
i believe anyone can accomplish this
anyone's going to be debt-free not to
put words in your mouth but i want to
make sure i understand you you consider
yourself a baby steps millionaire you
did it doing the baby steps
absolutely okay cool hey man thanks for
calling in and congratulations on number
12. whoa
wow
you got to be a millionaire just to feed
them
just to buy the bus
wow good for you man wonderful large
families are awesome this
is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
if you're struggling with money it's
easy to tell yourself that you'll deal
with it later i'll start fresh next year
but then later rolls around you're still
out of control
you have to decide
i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired i've had it this is the last month
i'm gonna do this
when you decide that we're ready to help
this month we're knocking 30 off a
12-month membership to our most
impactful life-changing
class and money products and tools
it's all included in a ramsey plus
membership when you do ramsey plus you
get access to financial peace university
which millions of people have gone
through this class learning how to not
only get out of debt but to become baby
steps millionaires like we're talking
about this hour you get the premium
version of our budgeting tool every
dollar
and you deserve a life uh free of
monthly payments and constant money
stress start your free trial of ramsey
plus today by texting trial to 33
789 text trial for a free trial to
ramsey plus to 33789
it is a millionaire theme hour we are
talking to people with a one million
dollar net worth or greater a net worth
is calculated
what you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities
it's not a feeling
it's not an income well a million
dollars isn't enough it's not a point
all people of a million dollars are evil
this is not a moral construct it's an
arithmetic formula
that's the deal
do you simply have what you own minus
what you owe equals 1 million or greater
if so you're a millionaire and i want to
talk to you
maybe it's worth 10 million i don't care
but i want to talk to you because you
actually have done it and people out
there need to hear what real people
sound like not people on talking heads
on stupid butt news channels
they need to talk to real human beings
and you're who it is so if you have a
million dollar net worth or greater call
me right now the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five greg is in des moines iowa
hi greg welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call dave sure
what's up
i was uh letting you know i was i'm a
millionaire good for you how much so
what is your net worth
one million one million dollars perfect
and uh give me a little breakdown on
that between the different classes
what's how much is in retirement mutual
funds how much is in real estate so on
roughly 450 in retirement
450 in real estate including a few
rental houses
and about 100 cash okay good for you how
old are you
38. how much of this one million dollars
did you inherit at 38 years old
you know we got a few bucks when my mom
died but that blew it
i think it was a couple thousand dollars
is all oh and it wasn't it had nothing
to do with with any of this okay so
you're not a millionaire because of an
inheritance that's the point okay
so uh very cool what do you do for a
living
i teach
you're a teacher what do you teach i am
uh healthcare
you teach healthcare
yeah in what what in what setting
community college city okay good for you
all right
so what your best year of household
income and your worst year of household
income
combined probably 200 best and worse is
probably 30 000 coming out of college
okay what's your wife do for a living
she also teaches healthcare oh very
interesting all right cool you know the
number three uh uh profession that we
found was teacher
as we in our millionaire study
doctors didn't make the top five
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
so
so
from you
that is envy are you with me
yeah i'm here okay so they got the
phones going so i i was filling till we
could get back to you so okay yeah i'm
guessing your degree is in healthcare
it is okay
and what was your gpa
uh 375 i think from my master's degree
oh wow good for you okay cool
so what's your advice to someone who
wants to have a million dollars by the
time they're 38 congratulations hero
well thank you
uh two things come to mind is one is of
course invest early and the other is
more important is simply be intentional
with your time your resources your
finances
are you back with me again coming in and
out
okay sorry about that greg i apologize
apparently we've not spent enough on our
technology here
um
we got a deal on it though i'll just
tell you um here we go
so what's your what's your advice to the
younger version of you you did this very
early
start early and be intentional
you know do things on purpose that's
pretty much it
okay yeah and just and do you feel like
you guys didn't have any life that you
just stayed at home and clipped coupons
and never came out except on triple
coupon thursday or whatever
no ten years ago we went to spain we
spent three weeks in barcelona and had a
great time we we had done everything we
wanted to do
okay
you've just been very careful very
intentional uh it's not like you're like
super frugal dumpster diving or
something for your food or something you
just made money and you made good money
i mean your best years 200 000 between
the two of you and uh and you turn
around and use that to build wealth
okay back to our construct because i'm
jumping around all over the place here
but
here's the thing
i have met
tens of thousands of millionaires in my
life
because of what i do
several years ago once i became a
millionaire i thought well i need to
meet some billionaire billionaires
because i don't have a billion and so i
need to talk to people about how to do
that
and i've now met i think 40 or 50
billionaires in my life
um i will tell you that out of those
billionaires and there's some strange
cookies that are billionaires okay
that's a different that's a different
that's a thousand million
okay so this is a millionaire times a
thousand is a billionaire
and so it's a different world than than
you know somebody with 10 million net
worth they're not even close to billion
it's a different world different mindset
different everything but even among
those uber rich
which are definitely probably not one
percenters are probably one half of one
percenters
out of all of those that i met i think
50 or 60 of them i lost count somewhere
around there how many i've met and had
conversation with not just drove by and
said hi and i just got a picture with
but i actually had a five or ten minute
or more conversation with developed a
plan whatever that kind of a thing out
of those people
two of them
are absolute
tools
horrible people
that i really you have to take a shower
after you meet them
but two out of any 60 people you meet
whether they have money or not qualify
for that
so it's not really any different so this
idea that the only way to become wealthy
is to be a crook or rip people off
is ludicrous
because by and large the way people
build wealth is they bring value to the
marketplace they're serving someone
they don't they don't just wait tables
they have a restaurant oh wait they
don't have one restaurant they have 10.
10 restaurants doing a good job taking
care of people
feeding them collecting money for
feeding them and they build a little
miniature restaurant empire you know
and so that's what's going on so the
idea that they inherit their wealth that
that's where money comes from nope
the idea that you have to be crooked to
be wealthy nope this is all small time
thinking by small time people that are
jealous
and envious
they're victims you're not a victim this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
it's an everyday baby steps millionaire
theme hour i'm dave ramsey your host
we're talking to real millionaires this
hour people have a net worth of a
million dollars or greater your net
worth is what you own
minus what you owe
and that determines whether or not
you're a millionaire you may not have a
goal to be a millionaire but you are
listening to a money show and the reason
for getting out of debt is not just to
feel better the reason for getting out
of debt is to be able to increase your
generosity increase your net worth
increase the stability in your life um
retire with your golden years take care
of your kids college all these kinds of
things it's not money that matters it's
what money does that matters the money
is useless
i mean enough lobster tastes like soap i
mean there's only so much you can do
with money but what it what you use it
for is why
people choose to acquire money
now how do you get to a million dollars
the fastest way i know is following the
baby steps
um and it is the most sure probability
let's talk to some real millionaires amy
is in dallas hi amy how are you
i'm great mr ramsay how are you better
than i deserve what is your net worth
uh 1.8 million okay cool break that down
for me by category a little bit
um i'd say um
750k is about you know 401ks roth iras
um 700 k's and
other stocks and mutual funds um house
and then um
cash as well
okay that's uh so you got about 250 in
cash
uh so stocks is about 700k and then
house is about 400k and then plus other
cash and then plus the 750 from the
401ks in roth ira gotcha how old are you
i'm 32 and my husband is 31. wow you did
this really fast congratulations how
much of this 1.8 million did you
none inherit my side i think my husband
got like 15 000 before we got married
but obviously that's not
indicative of why we have what we have
right for sure okay what's your best
year of working household income and
your worst year of working household
income
so we got married about three years out
of college so our best together was
about 120k or sorry worse together is
about 120k
our best
was probably last year at about 320k but
that's we got a couple big bonuses
that's not the average
okay
cool what do you all do for a living
uh
surprise surprise we're both engineers
okay
well you fit the model oh my gosh and
obviously you have engineering degrees
what were your gpas we do
uh mine was 3.3 my husband's was 3.1
that's not indicative that i'm smarter
than him though
i don't know i'm going with that i'm
going with that narrative i'm just
saying all right
so this is an impressive number
in a very short period of time
by 32 and 31 years old 1.8 million as
engineers making as engineers making a
high of 320 household income so
on that high year you had an
unbelievably fabulous income but you
guys have killed it what was your secret
um i mean if i could be honest i would
say it's four things
one i'm gonna give my parents a shout
out it's listened to them they've been
around the block
um so my dad
you know
he sat me down as soon as i got out of
college and said hey don't get enticed
by the shiny object you're going to be
making a lot more than you may
previously
set a budget and live by it
and i did and then number two
treat it as
not your money but it's a gift from god
that you're just stewards of you know so
it's never yours it's his and he's
trusting you to be a good steward for it
and then
three
same page as yourself
you know my husband i have never had a
disagreement about money ever and uh you
know before we got married we went to
this you know pre-marital counseling
with our pastor and he joked that we
were 99
compatible on financial principles which
like okay great because that's the
number one cause of divorce so we're
good there
and then um it's the fourth one is live
below your means we've never lived on
any more than 60 percent of our income
and we've never changed our lifestyle so
and by the way 60 of your income is
pretty dead gum sweet
yeah fair enough fair enough yeah i mean
you it's not like it's not like you
you're you're living you know in
somebody's basement or something i mean
you guys are killing me this is so well
done i'm so proud of y'all
this is excellent
absolute heroes okay so you just gave us
the formula live on less than you make
uh be on the same page with your spouse
keep the nobility factor going knowing
that you're a steward you're just you're
not an owner you're a manager for god
and
just use some common sense and you know
don't be a bass because bass get caught
by shiny objects
yeah i mean we've never changed our
lifestyle i mean i think i i remember
you guys asking
what's your most expensive pair of jeans
i think you've asked that before yeah
man i think mine's like 30 bucks and
it's not even the amount of money i
spent on jeans but i think it's the
amount of money we spend on clothes per
year i think our budget for the year is
150 on clothes per year
you're not clothing motivated what are
you motivated by
what is what is your thing what is your
what is your guilty pleasure you do
spend money on
if i could
i don't i don't i don't even know i
guess it's kind of weird i don't know
how to answer that because i think my
guilty pleasure is giving to others
like i love it
so like like if a family member calls me
and says hey amy i need your help with
this in a heartbeat yeah you know
so and i love doing that and i think my
husband teases me all the time because
i won't get expensive things for myself
which he loves because then he starts
you know hey anniversary i'll get her
this christmas and success yeah i won't
get it for myself but uh
yeah i think that's that's
i'll give you one thing we splurged on a
vehicle okay but it was the best thing
ever when we could uh
pay cash yeah
yeah yeah so what what is what is the
what's what was the splurge vehicle what
was it
it was a yukon xl recently okay recently
and you've got a 1.8 million dollar net
worth
yeah yeah you're not broke with six
student loans and four car payments and
a mastercard hanging around your neck
and then you go get a new yukon and go i
deserve it you didn't do that you got a
first you went and got a 1.8 million net
worth by the time you're 32. you guys
are amazing i'm honored to talk to you
very cool carol how are you what's your
net worth
i'm good dave great speaking to you my
net worth is 2.2 million good for you
give me a little breakdown on that by
category
uh 245 000 in real estate 100 000 in
cash and the rest is 401k and ira wow
big 401k okay killing it how old are you
i am 61. okay cool and how much of the
2.2 did you inherit
zero zero a lot of hard work okay are
you married or single
i am single divorced okay and uh how
long ago how long ago were you divorced
four years ago and i was told i'd be
bankrupt in a year but instead of being
bankrupt my portfolio has grown so yes
you don't look bankrupt to me
no i'm not yeah and that money that that
um 2.2 does not even include my
daughter's 529 plan which is about 100
000. wow way to go
so what is uh
been your average income over the years
um when i first started out contributing
to my 401k it was about 45 000 and now
i'm up to about 130. what do you do
i am a risk analyst
a risk analyst okay that makes sense
all right and what's your degree in
i have an associate's degree in business
administration
wow and what was your uh gpa during that
time
well obviously it was a while ago but i
was about 3.9 okay i went as an adult so
a little more focused than as a teenager
so gotcha okay what's your advice to the
younger version of you that's listening
to be able to have 2.2 million at 61
four years after a divorce
i would say slow and steady absolutely
take advantage of every program your
employer has to offer if they have a six
percent match in the 401k you put your
six percent in
and look at all your means i know i hear
that a lot on your show and absolutely
we live below our name so well done
carol proud of you excellent job
oh by the way we usually don't talk to
people that are savants either the
average gpa is around three
mine was 2.97 and i'm still pissed off
about that three one hundredths of a
point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
john 1 5 is our scripture of the day the
light shines in the darkness and the
darkness has not overcome it
abraham lincoln said character is like a
tree and a reputation like its shadow
the shadow is what we think of it the
tree
is the real thing
it's a millionaire theme hour as we talk
to real
millionaires people who really have
a million dollars or more not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion
not your little
socialist left-wing college professor
but people who really have a million
dollars how did they really
get it
john is in virginia beach john what's
your net worth
hi mr ramsey it's an honor to speak to
you it's a
2.15 million 2.15 good job give me a
little breakdown on that by category
uh iras from various rollovers are at
1 million hundred and twenty nine
thousand and uh
both the wife and i have two roths at
155 000 and then we have a joint like
electronic fund in there
at uh 57 000.
and then we have a home that's got about
134 000 left on it but valued at 620
000. so half a million there you counted
yeah we counted that as 486 and then
with our current jobs we got about 102
132 000 in uh
company 401ks wow okay cool how old are
you and an emergency fund i'm going to
be 57 in november and the wife turned 62
this year okay great how much of the
2.15 did you inherit
oh nothing okay
and um
they always sound surprised like
nothing of course
okay
so what's your uh best uh
your best working year uh household
income and your worst working year
household income
all right well in the 80s were married
in 86 so combined together i would say
we were
maybe at 50 000 a year and
peak earnings were
early 2000s say 2005
2006 before she semi retired and we were
probably
at 170 000. okay cool
what do you do for a living
i'm a satcom engineer okay
okay oh cool work with the military
gotcha and what about your wife what did
she do
she is semi-retired but she worked her
way up from a part-time cashier job to
being a district manager for
a major major fast food company
okay
all right
very cool yeah what's your degree in
we're dinosaurs dave my wife had one
semester and that's it with a college
diploma and i had a
renata college diploma high school
diploma i had a high school diploma
and uh i did a bunch of different you
know techie courses because i grew up
with the technology not like the kids
you know i had to grow into it so
um i may have enough matriculated
credits for an associates but i have
they told me to graduate at age 40 that
i would need uh
i don't know math english and philosophy
and basically at that time i was already
making good money and i said screw it
it's against your philosophy yeah
yeah
i love it
so what's your advice to the uh what's
your advice to the 24 year old version
of you that's listening out there do you
think they can still do it today and if
they can what should they do
oh absolutely definitely start in your
20s we got started late
you know we were on
america uh credit card merry-go-round
for years until we finally got tired of
it but yeah start early invest early and
you know live below your means and pay
for everything in cash save up and pay
for cash except for you know obviously
the house is a big ticket item but
i mean it can be done
yeah so you didn't take any huge risks
you just got out of debt lived on a
budget and invested
oh absolutely yes we have we've had an
investor for the last decade now that
helps us
a fiduciary investment firm gotcha very
cool
well hey man way to go john we
appreciate you sharing with us
congratulations you did it
so the 10 167 millionaires that we
studied
here's what we found i've already told
you 89
of them did not become millionaires
because
of
inheritance
79
that's 8 out of 10.
by the way when you're doing statistics
and you have something that's 79
that is a significant freaking number
that that establishes like a principle
it's not just like oh 52.4 percent and
we're not sure we've got all the votes
we need to actually make him president
you know i mean it's not that this is
not this is not hairline stuff here 79
is like everyone
okay when you hear a number like that in
a piece of research it's it's
statistically devastating
79 of a million of millionaires did not
attend
prestigious private schools
turns out where you go to school don't
matter
help you with that except for the
grammar when you're doing talk radio but
which it turns out you can have bad
grammar and still succeed
62 percent graduated from public state
schools 8 attended community college
nine percent
are high school graduates like our last
caller
68 of millionaires that's statistically
significant
use a financial advisor
to help them on their journey
73 of millionaires never
had a penny of credit card debt
7 out of 10 never had student loans by
the way half the population has had a
student loan
but 7 10 millionaires didn't
top three jobs already told you engineer
accountant and teacher
96
enjoyed
what they did for a career
i hate my job
is not something millionaires say very
often
i hate the place i work
is not something millionaires say very
often
if they feel that way they leave
that's kind of like integrity and stuff
one-third of millionaires never had a
six-figure household income
not even one year
33 percent
became millionaires without ever making
a hundred thousand dollar household
income
that one kind of blows my mind
i mean you it does help to earn more
money no kidding you know
wow the average millionaire lives in a
2600 square foot house that they have
lived in for 17 years
the average millionaire paid off their
home
in 11 years
the average millionaire in the ramsey
tribe that we did some separate research
on pays off their home in a little under
10 years
94 say they live on less than they make
93 use coupons
most of them hit millionaire status
right around age 49.
97
of millionaires believe they control
their own destiny
62 percent of the public believes that
belief
matters that's why we do this show
70 percent say they set some other
income aside for generosity every single
month
so
turns out there's a formula to building
wealth that is highly
predictable
invest in your 401k steadily
like baby step 4 15 of your income going
into retirement
after you've gotten out of debt and have
an emergency fund in place and then work
to pay your house off
if you pay your house off in 10 years or
less you're putting 15 of your income
away into retirement and you make an
average household income and you start
that process at 40 years old you will
retire with more than a million dollars
probably more than 5 million depending
on your household income
it just works these baby steps that we
teach
it is the shortest path it is just
simply works
but everybody's got to mess with it
everybody's got a gripe everybody's got
a whine everybody's got an opinion
and so we do these shows to go guys
these are real people that do this why
we call them baby steps millionaires
because they really freaking did this
does anybody do it perfect do most of us
have regrets no one does it perfect and
all of us have regrets we all could go
back and go well if i'd started then
think about how much if i hadn't done
that stupid butt thing how much i would
have we all have that but the point is
this formula is a predictable outcome
it is arithmetic
it's not happenstance
it's not by people like you
you are people like this
once you decide to be
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
jason senior producer for the ramsay
show did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week and
a lot of those people listen on one of
our 600 plus radio stations across the
country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you